few would have believed that the frail
asthmatic little boy who loved to
collect insects would amount to anything
special much less the youngest and most
robust president in US history
Theodore Roosevelt's transformation from
sickly child to master of the bully
pulpit and the ultimate symbol of
American strength and vitality is an
inspiring story of the power of
self-determination in this week's by
graphics we uncover his story Theodore
Roosevelt's the future 26th President of
the United States was born in New York
City on October the 27th 1858 to
Theodore Roosevelt senior and Martha
Bullock Roosevelt Roosevelt Senior was
one of the leading citizens of New York
City
Theodore junior who was known as TD was
the second child to the affluent couple
who lived in a luxurious home on
Manhattan Island TD he had a sister Anna
who was four years older than him a
younger brother Elias would follow two
years later and then there was another
sister Corrine year after that TD
suffered from asthma from the age of
three his condition indeed was so bad
that he spent much of his early years in
bet unable to attend school his parents
hired tutors to teach him from home
despite his own this young TD relished
the opportunity to learn once he had
learned how to read he became a
voracious devourer of books he loved to
fill his mind with tales of such Nordic
heroes as King Olaf and Erik threat he
was also fascinated with newspaper
stories about the exploits of the famous
British explorer dr. David Livingstone
TD he was a dreamer and he filled his
mind with dreams of tracking through
unchartered territories and discovering
hunting tribes young TD showed an
unusual curiosity about the natural
world one day born a trip to the market
he came across a dead seal in a
butcher's stall he was fascinated with
the find and returned daily to study and
measure it with a ruler eventually he
managed to take possession of the seal
skeleton and take it home where it
became the
exhibit of his Roosevelt Museum of
Natural History which he had set up in
his bedroom from the age of 16 he began
filling his journals with observations
about the natural world
his mother regularly took him on trips
to the country in order to help
alleviate his asthma and TD made the
most of this opportunity to wander
around in search of fish insects eels
and birds that he could analyze and then
write about the Roosevelt children they
were raised under the norms of Victorian
society as members of the upper class
they didn't mix with the less wealthy
and strict mores of decency were
enforced and manners and politeness were
of utmost importance
Sunday night was the day for religious
observance consisting of Church followed
by quiet contemplation TD hated Sundays
as this was the day when he was not
permitted to indulge in his natural
curiosity of the world in 1869 when he
was 10 years old titties family embarked
on a tour of Europe for 12 months the
children were exposed to the great
sights of England Germany France and
Italy yes TD he was not impressed he
later wrote I cordially hated it as did
my younger brother and sister
practically all the enjoyment we had was
in exploring any ruins or mountains when
we get away from our elders and in
playing in our different hotels when he
was 13 DD's father gave him his first
shotgun he was dismayed to find that he
was a terrible shot which brought a
ridicule from his peers what a friend's
challenged him to hit a billboard in the
distance he discovered the problem later
recalling not only was I able to read
the sign but I couldn't even see the
letters he was extremely nearsighted vus
had never realized it after telling his
father about the problem he was given a
pair of eyeglasses he wrote in his diary
I had no idea how beautiful the world
was until I got those spectacles with
his improved eyesight TD was able to
become even more obsessive with his
nature studies he learns taxidermy
stuffing and mounting birds that he shot
and adding them to his ever-expanding
Natural History Museum in the winter of
1872 1871 the Roosevelts made a trip to
the Mediterranean visiting Egypt the
Holy Land Syria Greece and Turkey
unlike the trip to Europe TD loved this
experience he made the most of the
opportunity
to shoot exotic birds and then stuff
them to take home and add to his
collection when he was 13
Diddy was sent off to Maine for a solo
trip to improve his health on the train
journey north he found himself in a
cabin with some other teenage boys in
the skinny week bespectacled a somatic
boy they found an easy mark
they roughed him up leaving him bruised
and humiliated when he returned home he
told his father about the incident
Roosevelt's senior told his son that he
needed to develop his body physically so
that he could defend himself a
prizefighter was hired in order to teach
the boy how to box from this point
onward TD became obsessed with building
his body he began lifting weights doing
calisthenics and running he developed a
great admiration for those who possessed
strength and displayed manly virility
he was also determined to live what he
called the strenuous life
the Roosevelts were a family that were
driven by goals and after returning from
their trip to the Middle East they set
one for their oldest son and that was to
gain entry to Harvard College in just
three years this was a terrific
challenge for young TD he had never gone
to school and although he was skilled in
languages nature in the classics he was
rather deficient in mathematics a
special tutor was hired and over the
next two years he worked hard to improve
his skills the hard work paid off and in
1875 he passed the Harvard entrance
exams for a freshman at Harvard the
childhood name of TD would never have
done so he took to calling himself
Theodore he immediately took to college
life involving himself in political
parades boxing tournaments and a rowing
competition he also became a skilled
debater taking on professors and fellow
students alike to his delight he found
himself readily accepted and was soon
invited to join some of Harvard's most
prestigious societies Theodore's
blissful existence it was interrupted
during a visit home in his sophomore
year he found that his father was
gravely ill with his beloved TD back
home the old man's health revived
somewhat and the danger seemed to have
passed but when Theodore returned to
Harvard for the new year his father took
a sharp turn for the worst towards the
end of February
Theodore received a telegram to return
home urgently he never made it in time
his father died that very night Theodore
was deeply depressed as a result of his
father's death however he refused to
show any of this pain to others
instigating a pattern that he would
continue for the rest of his life he
soldiered on disciplining his mind and
body to do what had to be done still his
grief it was evident in his actions
during a summer vacation to Oyster Bay
he rode his horse to exhaustion
when a dog insisted on chasing the horse
he turned and he shot it Theodore also
began hiking finding release in the
great outdoors he teamed with a crusty
old adventurer by the name of Bill
seawall who served as his guide see.well
later recorded his impression of
Theodore Roosevelt at the time stating
he was fair-minded Theodore was Zen's
then he took pains to learn everything
there was nothing beneath his notice I
liked him right off I liked him clear
though there wasn't a quality in him I
didn't like he wasn't had long or
aggressive except when necessary and as
far
as I could see he wasn't a bit cocky
though other folks thought so by his
mid-teens Theodore had developed into
quite a character never afraid to
express his opinion he could always be
counted on to be the center of attention
his unique outbursts of approval bully
and dee-lighted quickly became trademark
responses in 1879 he set his charms on a
young woman by the name of Alice Lee see
there girl he said to a Harvard pal she
won't have me but I'm going to have her
and have her he did he set out on a
campaign to win Alice's heart leading to
their engagement in early 1880 he had
all graduated from Harvard in June of
that year twenty first in his class of a
hundred and sixty students then in
October he and Alice were married after
a short honeymoon Theodore enrolled in a
law degree at Columbia University while
also working at his uncle's law firm
during his limited leisure time you
decided to learn about the war of 1812
when we couldn't find a decent book on
the subject he decided to write one
himself during the summer of 1881 the
young couple took a trip to Europe while
in Switzerland Theodore left his wife
behind while he climbs the Matterhorn
it was during this trip that he decided
to forgo a legal career and he was
determined to set his sights on becoming
a politician
[Music]
back then politics was actually seen as
being beneath men of wealth and various
friends tried to dissuade Theodore's
ambitions but that was always going to
be a losing proposition and on returning
to New York he joined the Republican
Party here he was associating with a
class of men that he hadn't previously
mixed with rough men who were skilled in
the low blows and dirty tricks of state
politics Roosevelt soon learned their
ways and within months it won the
party's nomination for a seat in the New
York State Assembly it was a solid
Republican seat and Roosevelt's he won
it handily Roosevelt turned up to take
his seat at the New York State Capitol
in Albany on January the 22nd 1882 he
cut the figure of a dandy with his fine
suit and his upper-crust ways he was
ridiculed by Democrats as well as
Republicans just like this he according
to his own recollection rose like a
rocket in New York politics
Roosevelt's politics they were grounded
in self-determination he firmly believed
that each man was in control of his own
destiny but he also realized that the
system it was grossly unfair with those
with the money and power having all of
the opportunities he made it his goal to
bring about a fairer system where all
Americans had the opportunity to succeed
when he wasn't working his way up the
political ladder in New York Theodore
ventured out west in order to fulfill
his love of adventure and the outdoors
in September of 1883 he made an
excursion to the Dakota badlands with
the express purpose of bringing home a
buffalo hat as a trophy
as with most things he set his mind to
he was successful in that goal during
this trip he also purchased a cattle
ranch in November of 1883 Theodore won
his third term to the New York State
Assembly he returns to Albany while his
wife who was heavily pregnant with their
first child went to live with his sister
On February the 11th 1884 he received a
long-awaited telegram announcing the
birth of a baby girl but this telegram
had also told him that Alice was very
sick he rushed home to discover that the
news was even worse both his wife and
his mother were gravely ill they both
died on the same day February the 14th
1884 that night erosion is
the light has gone from my life Theodore
responded to the double tragedy with the
stoicism that epitomized his personality
after a few days of isolation he left
the baby in the care of his sister and
returned to alberni to see out his term
in the general assembly life had to go
on throughout 1884 Roosevelt worked
tirelessly to propel himself from state
to national politics his brash and
wavering star brought in the attention
of prominent men including an
influential Bostonian by the name of
Henry Cabot Lodge by the end of the year
the 25 year old was being eyed by many
as a future Republican leader however
inside Roosevelt was an empty man he
needed to get away from the
rough-and-tumble of politics in order to
heal himself at the end of 1884
Roosevelt retired from politics and
moved to one of his ranches in North
Dakota
[Music]
Theodore Roosevelt turns up to the small
Dakota town of Medora dressed in
buckskins he brandished a brand-new
Winchester rifle as well as a hunting
knife that had bought from Tiffany's
jeweler's he was the quintessential dude
and was soon ridiculed by the hardened
locals despite this he revels in life in
the West he displayed a steely courage
which impressed all those who came to
know him Roosevelt hired his old
tramping guide bill see.well to come out
and manage his ranch for him but he
didn't leave all the hard work to his
men he rode out on the range with them
chased spooked cattle and stood guard
during long and bitterly cold nights in
1886 he captured a group of thieves who
had stolen a boat and then took them as
prisoners on a three-day trek to the
local sheriff during those three days he
didn't sleep a wink as he kept his rifle
trained on his captives following the
exceptionally harsh winter of 1886 -
1887 which killed half of his cattle
stock Roosevelt he returned east he was
30 pounds heavier than when he left and
was a harder more confident version of
himself soon after returning he met our
pans fell in love with a childhood
friend by the name of Edith Carow they
were married on December the 2nd 1886
and would go on to have five children
together
Roosevelt was soon approached by
Republican leaders and urged to re-enter
politics they wanted him to run for
mayor of New York he accepted and
campaigned hard to despite having little
chance of winning he came in third place
with 27% of the vote thinking that his
political career was over he next put
his efforts into writing the book the
winning of the West in 1888 Roosevelt
gave stump speeches for Republican
presidential candidate Benjamin Harrison
when he won the presidency Harrison was
persuaded by Theodore's political
champion Henry Cabot Lodge to appoint
the energetic Roosevelt to the u.s.
Civil Service Commission he took to the
role with a vengeance determined to
fight the corrupt spoil system and
enforce civil service laws in 1894
Roosevelt was appointed president of the
Board of New York City police
commissioners he then set about making
improvements to the structure of the
police force rooting out corruption and
imposing more stringent standards for
recruitment in 1897 again under the
urging of Henry Cabot Lodge new
president William McKinley appointed
Roosevelt as the assistant secretary of
the Navy he became a strong advocate for
the building of the strength of the Navy
when on February 15 1898 the u.s.
warship Maine exploded in Havana Harbor
Roosevelt took it upon himself to order
a number of ships to prepare for war
when war was declared a short time later
Roosevelt resigned his post and forms
the first u.s. volunteer cavalry
regiment he was determined to be in the
thick of the action
[Music]
the press dubbed Roosevelt's cavalry
regiments the Rough Riders after a
period of training in San Antonio Texas
they were shipped to Cuba their first
action was at the Battle of las gracias
where they forced the Spanish to abandon
their entrenched positions on July the
1st 1898 Roosevelt led his men on the
famous charged up kettle Hill he was the
only man on horseback making an easy
target for the enemy still without any
care for his own safety he rode up and
down the line urging his man up the hill
also attempting to take the hill were
soldiers of the 9th u.s. cavalry but
these soldiers were having a hard time
of it a reporter for The New York Times
recorded the action stating Colonel
Roosevelt on horseback broke from the
woods behind the line of the 9th and
finding its men lying in his way shouted
if you do not wish to go forward let my
men pass please the junior officers of
the 9th with their Negroes instantly
sprang into line with the Rough Riders
since charged at the blue block house on
the right I speak of Roosevelt first
because he was without doubt the most
conspicuous figure in the charge
Roosevelt mounted high on horseback and
charging the rifle pits at a gallop and
quite alone made you feel that you would
like to cheer he wore on his sombrero a
blue polka-dot handkerchief which as he
advanced floated out straight behind his
head like a guide on having reached the
crest of the hill Roosevelt dismounted
and urged his men to follow him but
there was yet another hill to conquer
and no sooner had the Rough Riders
scrambled to the top of kettle Hill than
their dashing Colonel set off for San
Juan Hill his men overpowered the
Spanish resistance and took possession
of both Hills in the process Roosevelt
killed a Spanish trooper who he said
doubled over like a jackrabbit
following victory in Cuba Roosevelt
returned to New York where he was
convinced to run for governor
campaigning vigorously on his war record
he won by just 1% of the popular vote
during his time as governor he developed
the style and platform which would
underpin his later presidency it was a
passionate advocate for the rights of
the underprivileged was against large
corporations and monopolies and
champions the preservation of natural
resources in 1900 Henry Cabot Lodge and
other prominent Republicans urged
Roosevelt's to throw his hat into the
ring for the vacant Republican vice
presidential spot in the upcoming
presidential
elections though reluctance he won the
Republican nomination pairing with
President McKinley with his boundless
energy threw himself into a barnstorming
campaign making 480 speeches in 23
states in the end he and McKinley easily
won and Theodore Roosevelt was sworn in
as the vice president of the United
States on March the 1st 1901 six months
later President McKinley was shot while
attending the pan-american exposition in
New York he died eight days later as a
result the 42 year old Roosevelt was
propelled into the highest office in the
land
becoming the 26th President of the
United States on September the 14th 1901
he was the youngest man to ever hold the
position Roosevelt was a very different
man to William McKinley still the vows
that he would continue to pursue the
policies of his predecessor at the same
time he was determined to stamp his mark
on the presidency in order to win a
second term in his own right a large
part of the focus of Roosevelt's
domestic policies were focused on
breaking up the monopolies of big
business he instituted 44 antitrust
suits forcing the breaking up of the
northern securities company and putting
regulatory controls on Standard Oil of
all the domestic policies that Roosevelt
was passionate about however none came
close to the preservation of Wildlife
than the environment he established the
United States Forest Service created
five national parks and placed a total
of two hundred and thirty million acres
of lands and a public protection in
terms of foreign policy Roosevelt he was
an ardent imperialist he successfully
mediated the Treaty of Portsmouth which
brought an end to the rush of Japanese
war winning a Nobel Peace Prize for his
efforts his making of a deal with the
Panamanian government for the building
of a canal led to the separation of
Panama from Colombia in 1903 in the 1904
presidential election the Democrats put
up Alton Brooks Parker to face off
against Roosevelt campaigning on the
promise to give every American a square
deal Roosevelt won 56 percent of the
popular vote along with 336 of 476
electoral votes during a second term in
office Roosevelt began moving to the
left of his Republican base he pushed
for a number of pretty radical reforms
including the eight-hour
today most of which they were defeated
in the house he had declared that he
would not seek a third term and so he
became a lame-duck president while
thoroughly enjoying the role of
presidents he felt that staying in
office for more than two terms would run
the risk of dictatorship
following the end of his second term in
office in March of 1909 Roosevelt went
on an African safari with a group of
prominent scientists and hunters the
expedition was on behalf of the
Smithsonian Institute and was charged
with bringing back specimens for the
Institute's museums the trip was
successful and the group came back with
eleven thousand four hundred specimens
ranging from insects to elephants when
he returned to the United States
Roosevelt was far from happy with the
performance of his successor William
Taft believing that Taft had made the
Republicans far too conservative he
began to speak loudly of leading a
program of new nationalism which
emphasized labor over capital by the
time that the 1912 presidential election
rolled around Roosevelt was convinced
that only he could save the Republican
Party he challenged haft in the
Republican primary however Taft won the
nomination squeezing Roosevelt to the
sidelines undeterred Roosevelt quit the
Republicans forming his own party the
progressives and he ran for president as
an independent he then went to the
stumps and appealed to the people on
October the 14th 1912 Roosevelt was
giving a speech in Milwaukee Wisconsin
when he was struck by an assassin's
bullet this shot was a perfect shot to
the heart and it penetrated his
breast-pocket
and slammed into a thick glasses case
the bullet then thumped into a heavy
speech manuscripts that he had chosen
not to use without missing a beat
Roosevelt ensured that the would-be
killer was apprehended then he went
right on with his speech the first words
to the crowd after being hit were ladies
and gentlemen I don't know whether you
fully understands that I have just been
shot but it takes more than that to kill
a bull loose the bullet stayed in
Roosevelt's pectoral muscle until his
death the 1912 presidential election it
was won by the Democratic candidate
Woodrow Wilson with 42% of the popular
vote however Roosevelt did beat the
incumbent president with 27% compared to
23% for Taft during a South American
expedition in 1913 to 1914 Roosevelt
contracted tropical fever after
suffering a leg wound which became badly
infected by the time he returned to New
York he was 50 pounds lighter and
deathly pale
[Music]
the last few years were wracked with
pain for the once robust outdoor
adventurer malaria bouts were common as
were complications of his leg
inflammation the end came in the very
early morning hours of January the 6th
1919 after he had complained about not
being able to breathe the night before
the doctor was summoned and after some
treatments he felt better however he
died in his sleep as a result of a blood
clot in the lungs when he heard of his
father's demises oldest son Archibald
telegraphed his siblings with the words
the old lion is dead
you know Roosevelt it was 60 years old
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several times a
week and if you're looking for something
else why not check out some of our
videos from the archive that I'm
thinking too on the screen now and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]